the 41st president will be honored with
four days of memorials and events before
reaching his final resting place at
O'Keefe is at Joint Base Andrews in
Maryland where President Bush will be
brought later today
edie good morning good morning bianna
President Bush's casket will be flown
here on a jet normally known as Air
Force One but his final flights have
been dubbed special air mission 41 from
here he will be taken to the US Capitol
where he will lie in state in the
Capitol Rotunda until Wednesday morning
that's when a motorcade will transport
the casket through Washington to the
National Cathedral for a state funeral
president Trump and First Lady Melania
Trump planned to attend President Bush's
casket will then be flown back to
Houston for a public viewing and private
funeral service at st. Martin's
Episcopal Church on Thursday morning
Lokomotiv 4141 well escort President
Bush's casket to Texas A&M University in
2005 Union Pacific Railroad painted the
train the colors of Air Force One to
honor mr. Bush finally Thursday
afternoon the 41st president will be
laid to rest at the gated family plot at
the Bush Presidential Library on the
grounds of the campus he will lie next
to his wife Barbara and their daughter
Robin who died of leukemia at the age of
three back here the forecast this
afternoon calls for clear skies just the
kinds of conditions the formal naval
pilot would love for flying Viana
Edie thank you